c'est surtout une manière de montrer
l'hypocrisie de l'union européenne et de
certains gouvernements occidentaux de
continuer à s'engager à soutenir la
frange la plus extrémiste et la plus
radicale de l'opposition
monsieur représentée par monsieur croix
des oiseaux qui exige que les sanctions
contre le peuple vénézuélien et
j'insiste dont souffre le peuple
vénézuélien soit renforcée c'est à dire
que ces gens demandent à certains pays
occidentaux de martyriser leurs peuples
quand ils ne demandent pas directement
une intervention militaire pour détruire
le venezuela donc jeu qu'est ce qui va
se passer le 7 décembre
écoutez le 7 décembre le venezuela aura
une nouvelle assemblée nationale
équilibré en tout cas il y aura des
députés d'opposition il y aura des
députés du chavisme
et cet ensemble de la représentation
législatives nationales aura
certainement des débats de fond
mais en tout cas elle s'engagera
remettre la la politique vénézuélienne
sur les rails constitutionnel
cette politique évidemment avait été
complètement dévié par les tentatives de
putsch à répétition instauré par les
états unis et leurs pantins du roy noyau